do you think about kids is that
something that you think about for your
future yeah a lot I mean this there's
not a day goes by when I don't think
about I mean I'm right in that in the
period of time and as is my girlfriend
so we're deeply it's funny though we're
in the one I think probably the first
generation that's intellectualizing it
rather than just going on pure
primordial instinct we are dealing with
seemingly insurmountable challenges in
society with you know looming inevitable
economic collapse environmental
destruction it's a question about the
responsibility of bringing more children
in to the world you know you're thinking
big picture I am you know you can't help
it you making a decision of that
magnitude I think you have to you owe it
to yourself and maybe you don't new in
this total you know overthink everything
to the point of insanity but that's just
the way God made me well four kids are a
possibility for you yeah that was a lot
of those along answer should have just
said yes kids were possibility
you